[Music]
leslie odom jr treated everyone to a
powerful pre-show performance at the
2021 oscars
[Music]
ahead of the academy awards on sunday
night the multi-hyphenate performer sang
speak now from the one night in miami
[Music]
soundtrack
yeah the track earned him an oscar nom
for best original song
but that's actually just one of his two
nominations for the regina king helmed
picture
but we are fighting for our lives
you know i know what's going on out
there right
leslie was also nominated for best
supporting actor for his portrayal of
legendary singer sam cook you know who
gets paid more than the writer of a song
that hits number 94 on the billboard hot
100
the writer of a song that hits number
one back in march leslie opened up to
e.t about what the double nominations
meant to him
how does it feel to celebrate not one
but two
oscar nominations today
man uh i i have been
watching movies and you know a lover of
the cinema since i was a little boy so
in so many ways this feels like alpha
doesn't sound weird but it feels like
the beginning
of something it feels like um uh film is
such a public way to learn
so i feel like the last you know the
last half decade or so has been i've
just been trying to learn all i can and
this feels like just the
you know like i'm not embarrassing
myself i love that you know you are only
the fourth person to get a double
nomination um for acting and songwriting
what how does that sink in um it's
it means a lot on this movie in
particular this movie meant
so much to me and to all of us but the
fact that i
i saw an early cut of regina's beautiful
movie and i was so moved by it
so i just was you know i was happy to be
part of it i was thrilled that i got to
bring more of myself
to the project it's deeply meaningful i
loved listening to your co-stars in the
jungle talk about how when you started
singing
and they were like where's the track
playing sam cook this is sam cook track
playing somewhere
you brought life and meaning to sam cook
for so many who
may not have known about him and his
activism
and what does that mean to you
well in the places that i
felt i fell short or that i might have
been
deficient in some way i leaned on sam's
confidence
you know and then in many ways sam has
been a teacher
um to me almost my whole life
you know his voice has been in my ear
and uh he gave me even more
working on this project you know